I mean we started with the puzzle we're
all agreed there is a puzzle we seem to
make constant progress on all sorts of
things and yet we don't seem to arrive
lots of people have thought were just
about to arrive throughout human history
Lord Kelvin being the obvious scientific
example said there's nothing more for us
to do in science now the more and more
precise measurement that was before
Einstein appeared before quantum
mechanics before we split the atom
before quarks and leptons before dark
energy dark matter and so forth hawking
was saying you know where it's just
around the corner we're gonna have a
theory of everything so forth we all
know at some level it's not going to
happen is it we just know that it's not
like we're going to come across the
answer close down our universities we
all know it publish the results and and
it's all over guys no it's not gonna
happen and the question is why is it not
going to happen and my response to that
it's not going to happen because our
theories and our language do not
describe reality that's not what is
going on there are ways of holding the
openness of the world and there are
tools to enable us to intervene in the
world and they can be immensely powerful
but I think we have to give up the
theological notion and I think it is a
theological notion that we are
uncovering the ultimate character and
reality of the world and if you think
about it you just start with perception
our perception is not a mirror of what's
out there you know when the art when we
see something in our are our eyes our
eyes response to the world it doesn't
somehow map the world it responds to the
world you know the others the the eye
responds by at the firing of a neurone
that's its response and so the human
being functions by responding to the
openness of what's out there it does so
by creating things the firing of the
neuron and it intervenes on the basis of
that thing that is created
in response to the world and we can do
very well as a result of that the firing
of the neurone doesn't describe
something out there it's a response and
thought and language are exactly the
same they are responses higher level
closures as I would describe it so the
firing of the neurons a very low level
closure but we have a higher level
closures and those higher level closures
provide us with ways to intervene just
as the firing of the neuron provides us
with a way of intervening but let us not
imagine that that they somehow describe
some stuff which is utterly different
which is you know out there as it were
which I want to refer to as openness so
we're not tempted to think that it's
something in particular things are a
function of what we do with our closures
we make things to enable us to intervene
just one final thing why aren't we so
attached to this theological notion of
reality and I think there are a couple
of ways one one reason is because we
somehow think that if we give it up
anything goes we can make up any old
stuff and I don't think that's right we
can't make up any old stuff we have to
refine our closures we have to make them
better we have to make our tools work
better and we can be very very precise
about how we make the tools and I think
the other thing is we feel that we would
be lost we would somehow feel like the
medieval monks felt with the idea with
the arrival of the Enlightenment that
they'd have to give up the safety of
knowing where they are with God and I
think we just think no that's not right
instead if we give up on the idea of an
ultimate reality we have the potential
to create our ways of holding world
which are limitless and which give us
limb unlimited potential to intervene
and achieve things that we're not
achieving at the moment but let us not
imagine that any of them however
sophisticated they are are actually
somehow going to reach through human
concepts and human experience and touch
the world out there in some precise and
final way